osiander meine damen und herren hosianna
kurz vor dem ersten advent wurde der
union ein neuer heilsbringer geboren und
siehe es war ein super jahr
markus benedikt maria söder zwei meter
10 geballtes franken testosteron beet
und co schreiben ihnen hier gerade
achten sie mal darauf mit aller gewalt
zum kommenden kanzler warum weil der
markus auf dem cdu parteitag in leipzig
so eine geile rede gehalten hat und
müssen wir sagen weil sich die union
nach führung sind ist ja so nach kerl
entschuldigung nach köthen ist fakt die
frau merkel reist ihre üblichen termine
noch auch nur noch so runter mehr oder
weniger lustlos gestern zb die
alljährliche übergabe des
weihnachtsbaums im kanzler
es ist jedes jahr ich weiß ich weiß aber
ja aber selbst so ein
das ritual könnte man doch etwas
peppiger moderieren die adventszeit die
weihnachtszeit ist eine zeit der
vorfreude aber wir wissen auch dass das
leben oft schwierig ist und deshalb
freuen wir uns auf weihnachten freuen
uns darauf dass jesus geboren wurde
gut
sehen wir das positive wegs ist musste
sie den namen jesus nicht ablesen
diese woche hat unsere kanzlerin im
bundestag für eine rede mal kurz so
getan als würde sie sich noch für
politik interessieren aber er glaubt ihr
das noch mal ganz ehrlich wie lange soll
das mit dieser groko noch so weitergehen
vieles muss noch weiter gemacht werden
deshalb finde ich
wir sollten die legislaturperiode land
weiter habe meine persönliche meinung
ich bin dabei also ich frag mich gut ich
würde genauso weitermachen
markus söder wird doch nur so gehabt
weil es das sonstige unions
führungspersonal nicht mehr bringt mein
gott hat frau kramp karrenbauer hat ak
den saal da beim cdu-parteitag sie dort
mit ihrer rede haben sie es gesehen aber
das hat sich gezogen wirklich schlimm
und seien wir ehrlich auch als
verteidigungsministerin konnte sich die
frau ja bis jetzt nicht wirklich
profilieren wir haben die hubschrauber
jetzt ausgeliefert bekommen und diese
hubschrauber sind an sich auch flugfähig
das will ich an der stelle deutlich
sagen
aber ja sie sind technisch sie sind
technisch flugfähig sie fliegen halt nur
nicht also technisch feierlich feierlich
wofür steht diese cdu noch nach ihrem
parteitag nach dem was da beschlossen
wurde in leipzig sie steht für die
schwarze null plus das verhindern von zu
viel klimaschutz zu viel europa und
zuviel frauenquote das ist es wir wissen
doch nur noch was sie alles nicht sind
und die cdu es auch nicht die partei die
sich von öko aktivisten aufs dach
steigen lässt und das c wegnehmen es
doch auch die partei seid ihr eine
nachricht aufs dach gestiegen und hat
euch das c weggenommen ja was ich damit
sagen will es ist kein wunder mal da und
dann ist es kein wunder dass der sänger
markus im kontrast zu diesen leuten so
blendend dasteht als heilsbringer und
immerhin müssen wir ihm zugutehalten hat
er sicher völlig neu erfunden jahre lang
rechts geblinkt jetzt plötzlich
bayerischer wien oder vom dienst das
nennt man lernfähig was allerdings seine
umjubelte rede von leipzig angeht
die war jetzt nicht brandneu in dem
sinne haben wir herausgefunden also ich
sag mal so es gibt gewisse parallelen zu
der rede die er neulich erst im oktober
beim csu-parteitag gehalten hat wenn man
genau hinhört
liebe freunde tempo in der politik wird
nicht gemacht von uns ist tempo der
veränderungen machen nicht wie manch
einer für den ist ein suv fast schlimmer
als ein akw
manch einer glaubt ja dass ein suv
schlimmer sei als ein atomkraftwerk
sowie in bremen zwar doch in bremen auch
so eine abgewählte rot grüne regierung
ich gestehe den grünen moral so ich
glaube sogar wir haben zum teil auch
mehr moral als wie sie haben nämlich
eine viertel nur als eine doppelmoral
liebe freunde das sollten wir den
bürgern
land endlich sagen liebe freunde hallo
echo
da kommt markus söder ist jetzt halt
umweltaktivist das heißt der recycelt
natürlich seine reden
die waren noch gut warum sondern neu
schreiben erstaunlich ist nur wie
unterschiedlich sein
nennen wir sie mal gags so ankamen auf
beiden parteitagen hier zunächst bei der
cdu ich kriege mal den satz zu hören wir
müssen der fels in der brandung sein
dann stelle ich die frage da wo du
stehst gibt es gar kein wasser mehr
[Applaus]
überhaupt kein wasser so und jetzt
selber witz und die resonanz bei der csu
manchmal höre ich dass man sagt markus
wir müssen fels in der brandung sein
dann frage ich immer ist dort wo du
deinen fans vermuten ist überhaupt noch
was
seitdem nennen sie ihn in der csu nur
noch den joker
ich sage immer ich sags ja immer als
guter comedian musst du die stille auch
mal aushalten und es kommt natürlich
immer aufs publikum an jeder ist anders
manche wollen sich halt amüsieren hallo
deutsche komiker eure gags sind
rohrkrepierer
das muss nicht sein bucht jetzt das
dankbarste publikum der welt die cdu die
grünen sind für die völlige freigabe von
drogen aber beschließen jedes mal
regelmäßig fleisch muss verboten gehören
liebe beide absolut null punkte und
trotzdem ein sprünge vor begeisterung
und ist wenn die bundeskanzlerin bayern
lob dann nur weil es nicht anders geht
wirklich das dümmste publikum der welt
zudem für ein deutschland in dem dir gut
und gerne lachen
[Applaus]
ja
diese woche hat uns der joker übrigens
noch eine echt gute pointe beschert
bayern verlässt und hielt damit den
sogenannten nationalen bildungsrat der
sollte eigentlich mehr vergleichbarkeit
ins deutsche schulsystem bringen
denn wie sie sicher wissen leisten wir
uns ja 16 verschiedene schulsysteme
warum wir nicht mehr mitmachen beim
bildungsrat wir befürchten auch dass am
ende ein berliner zentralabitur des
zieles und der bund kann gerne geld
geben also wenn der bund uns gehen und
geld geben will oder auch den anderen
bundesländern üblich total dafür
ich habe kein problem damit auch wie nat
das geld würden eben toll
die kultusministerkonferenz versagt seit
jahrzehnten bei der angleichung der
schulsysteme
deswegen bleibt umziehen mit
schulpflichtigen kindern innerhalb
deutschlands ein echtes abenteuer im
übrigen ein etwas vergleichbares abi
wäre doch im sinne bayerns so ungerecht
dass man da mehr arbeiten muss für einen
guten nc ich verstehe das alles nicht
deswegen muss ich jetzt nachsitzen im
bayerischen kultusministerium bei
christian ehring
[Applaus]
und willkommen bei meinem seminar warum
bayern schulsystem einen anderen brutal
überlegen ist und jedes kind das
woanders geboren wird leider von natur
aus über ist so woher kommt die denn
eigentlich unsere für alle anderen
bundesländer so niederschmetternde
geistige überlegenheit
ja ich hatte mal eine ganz andere frage
warum glaubt ja ich das euro schulen so
viel besser sind da unten in den
bayerischen inn zählern ich meine
woher kommt diese unglaubliche arroganz
arroganz wie sind wir versuchen andere
sagen wir mal intellektuell
herausgeforderten bundesländern zu
helfen wenn immer mehr aus
bundesbildungsministeriums sagt na ja in
einigen anderen ländern ist die bildung
wirklich am wackeln
da kann ich nur sagen null problem
bayern als vorbild nehmen dann
funktioniert
da wir auf die toilette ich möchte kurz
kotzen nein dafür ist die pause
also warum sind wir so viel besser als
ihr anderen rand üben weil wir früh aus
sieben ja schon in der vierten klasse
gibt es in bayern das sogenannte
grundschule abitur knallharte tests nur
wer da in deutsch mathe und heimatkunde
einen bestimmten notenschnitt erreicht
darf aufs gymnasium
alle anderen müssen auf die doofen
schule zu den dom
die werden dann schlosser oder
verkehrsminister keine ahnung was so wie
eben so machen in bayern haben schon
neunjährige burnout und wir sind stolz
darauf
hamburg hingegen hat solche schüler hier
schon mal persönlich irgendwo ein homo
sapiens gesehen wird das gesehene ein
bayerischer schüler müsste aus dem stand
der korrekte plural heißt andersrum
ich dachte hinterland dass haring
mich regt das auf mich regt es wirklich
auf das bei euch in bayern so viele
sachen regelrecht funktionieren in allen
bundesländern fehlen ohne ende lehrer
nur bei euch in bayern nicht wie macht
ihr das
da haben wir einen trick wir stellen
jedes jahr eine sogenannte schüler
prognose das heißt schreibt es auf wir
zählen tatsächlich einmal im jahr wie
viele kinder geboren wurden und dann
wissen wir jetzt kommt der hammer
wie viele in sechs jahren zur schule
gehen das ist zauberei und das ist noch
nicht alles dann stellen wir die lehrer
die wir brauchen
gleichzeitig ein doch gibt es doch nicht
da sind wir in bayern und in berlin
nummer zum vergleich in berlin hat sie
neulich eine schule stinke frei weil da
keiner medicus putzt also kleine oliver
ho schickt man seine kinder lieber zur
schule in bayern oder in stinkt ihm bei
trotzdem diese arroganz von euch regt
mich auf alle anderen bundesländer
rotieren ständig mit den sommerferien
bayern sagt einfach stumpf wir wollen
aber über im august ferien haben ende
vorsicht dafür haben wir ein absolut
schlüssiges argument nämlich im august
ist es am schönsten so der uni war
schreibt jetzt 100 mal an die tafel ich
schäme mich für mein nrw witz abitur und
ich muss auch schon los langes
wochenende
am montag ist wieder einer von diesen
feiertagen die es nur in bayern gibt
maria besäufnis oder sogar
für weitere videos klickt unten und
abonniert auch unseren channel alles im
kasten
ok wo geht's hier raus
scheiße